this morning we have new information on
the trump administration's impact on
families
trying to cross the u.s southern border
lawyers say they cannot find the parents
of listen to this number
545 children after they were separated
at the border
the children are now in u.s custody and
some of them have not seen their parents
in more than three
years maria viral reports on the efforts
to track them down
in the aclu filing lawyers say of the
1030 separated migrant children
they still haven't been able to reach
parents for 545
kids and roughly two-thirds of those
parents are believed to have been
deported
to their countries of origin the
children in question
were separated before the trump
administration fully implemented its
short-lived zero tolerance policy i
didn't like
the sight or the feeling of families
being separated
it's been more than two years since
president trump ended that policy
which separated more than 2800 children
from their families at the southern
border
a federal judge then required the
administration
to reunite children with their parents
within 30 days
a deadline it did not meet our advice on
that
wasn't sought out scott schucart a
former homeland security official told
60 minutes in 2018
that one of the government's problems
was tracking the families it separated
the aclu filing offers more evidence of
that claim which was also confirmed
by a november 2019 inspector general
report
citing widespread errors in the
government's methods
people were removed to other countries
without there being good records of what
adult went with what child
in july 2018 we spoke with bernardino
contreras trejo and his daughter
fernanda
they were reunited 27 days after they'd
been separated at the border
he told us officials at the border said
you mean nothing
you don't have any rights here we're
going to take your daughter away
did you know that it was possible i
didn't know that it was possible they
could separate me from my kid he said
as for fernanda she said that they
treated her bad and
scolded her how do you feel when you
hear that
powerless
a report issued by the health and human
services department actually shows that
children separated
from their parents at the border were
more likely to have higher levels of
fear abandonment post-traumatic stress
and likely to consider self-harm or even
suicide and gail we have spoken with a
number of these families and their
children they say there are some big
psychological impacts
that they will be dealing with for a
very long time gail
ray this is heartbreaking we went to
texas at the time
matter of fact saw you there too we saw
those people
with their families were there some bad
eggs in the group maybe
but that's not what we saw what we saw
were desperate people
trying to come here for a better life
for their children and for themselves
and to protect their children i can't
understand why there wasn't a system in
place
to keep track of the kids once they were
separated from their parents we wouldn't
stand for this
if somebody did this to american
children we would not stand for this
do you have do you happen to know how
the system worked
you know gail i think a lot of this
happened because the policy was
implemented so
quickly that the administration couldn't
coordinate properly with all the federal
agencies that were involved
we were talking about nearly a dozen of
them that were impacted from border
patrol dhs to the department of
health and human services that we just
talked about right now so i think the
coordination
was a very very big issue people were
just caught off guard
and they didn't know and didn't have a
tracking system in place it's
heartbreaking it should be all hands on
deck to straighten this out thank you
very much maria thank you very much